we now have be good to yourself
crewnecks available in light blue maroon
and cement that embankment gang color
you know it check these out along with
the new windbreaker at Theo
vonstore.com and thank you for your
support
I've got some new tour dates to announce
we will be going to Newark New Jersey
May 10th
um Westbury New York May 11th
um and you can get pre-sale tickets to
those shows with code Rat King starting
Wednesday January 25th at 10 A.M eastern
time and the General on sale starts
Friday January 27th at 10 A.M Eastern
Time
I will be in Las Vegas on June 30th and
July 2nd at The Encore Theater we've
also added a seventh show in Austin on
June 9th and a fourth show in Houston on
March 23rd
um all other shows and dates uh
theovan.com
t-o-u-r make sure to go there to get uh
the best pricing available and um and
follow those links and uh looking
forward to seeing you guys
oh man
I bought this button-up shirt
I got it on
I don't know if I like it I don't know
if I like being in this I don't like I
will say it I don't like being in this
sort of shirt I don't like
you know this is the concept we're gonna
button you up boy
we're gonna button you up you little
nasty boy
I just feel like they're like getting
you ready for
I don't know
feel like somebody's just packaging you
up
in some like a formatted
I feel like I'm being formatted you ever
formatted a document or something on
Microsoft Word and
you got the document how you want it
you did as much as you could you got a
couple extra commas in there
if you like me I.E dude I unlimited
commas bro
oh I do unlimited commas
Tiffany comma
Ben comma
[__] the comma neighbor
all caps unlimited commas bro but then
you do formatting and it puts it into
nor you know regular whatever so the
teacher can grade it
and you give it to the teacher and like
this is a history report what does this
have to do with anything and I'm like
well
that's that's history baby Tiffany been
[__] a neighbor you know what I'm
saying because that's history boo that's
in the books
that's in God's library now son because
she did it
so
anyway I'm in a button up and for me
that's a lot you know I you know and
also I never liked uh because when I was
young all the rich kids they wore
button-ups
they had the buttons and
and it was buttoned up and damn they
just you know
their lives look buttoned up
and I didn't like them I just didn't
like it it resembled something I didn't
like
I think in some ways organization or so
I don't know
but something about it just always made
me feel uncomfortable
but that's old [__]
and today I'm doing it I'm wearing it
I'm buttoned up for you
today and with you today
and I'm grateful uh
I'm excited to be here you know
I'm excited to be here a lot of
interesting stuff uh just been going on
in my life and in your life and I want
to hear about some of it and and um and
talk about some of it and share you know
um
but I feel a little formatted I feel
like
you know this button up got me feeling
you know just damn caged up
I don't know what I'm talking about
and I never have baby I'm happy to be
here with you today let's get into it
welcome to this past weekend
[Music]
whenever you're down
faithless and died your stories Untold
come take my hand and walk there with me
I know play
where we can be free
there is a light shining for you
guiding your way
Shadows
[Music]
where we
came from the mountains out under the
deepest
calling you
is the rising sun shining in the
Darkness
[Music]
so that's a slow tune that's it you know
that's something we went with and I you
know there's something about it I like
there is a light
you know there is a
there is something to see that will keep
you warm there is a
there is a possibility
there's something about that that always
because it's hard to see a lot of times
man
it's hard to see
it's hard to see that possibility
I struggle with it a bunch man it's not
I don't want to see it I don't I don't
want to see your possibility
I want to sit right here and boil
I want to boil in this dang
and just in this damn
in this anger broth
I just want to boil in this anger broth
I mean it's hard to sometimes see some
possibility
[Music]
um
but it's always there and usually it
finds you
I notice when I'm fuming boy
when I'm damn just I mean just huffing
my own damn
I'm just huffing my own [__] anger
Duster
I'm damn just huffing the damn keyboard
cleaner of my [__] anger
some type of possibility breaks in
somebody makes me laugh something
happens I see a thing a bird will fly by
and shat on somebody window God damn
and that's when God's breaking through
and saying hey
there's possibility out there for you
um
what's going on man it has been I just
got back from Paris baby
France son and
I've never liked the French I'll be
honest with you
if you put 70 French people in front of
me
I don't like them
I don't I get they just the way they
they're like
[Music]
um
they just it sounded like um
you just want to just Pat them on the
[__] back boy
I just want to spray paint my hand red
white and blue and Pat them [__] on
the back
and get the [__] truth out of them
what are you trying to say yeah
it sounds like Japanese but they [__]
got their but their uh nasaled out or
something
you sound like somebody hit a bunch of
cotton in a Japanese dude
[Music]
foreign
god dude
you just can't get it sounds like
somebody's just e-jacking out into this
just somebody just got stuck ejaculating
you know
like
what the [__] you talking about
so anyway I'm angry I guess I am I I'm
[__] keyed up today man
a lot of [__] going on I'm trying to
quit that being that being vaping it's
vaping [__]
so I'm still on that [__] dude God damn
I'll [__] put my tongue in a in a
damn birdhouse baby and lick the walls I
don't care
that's just where I'm at today dude
thank you
I'll eat a damn Bird's ass bro
no cat
praise God man we're working through it
um but dude I went to France we went to
a lot has happened
um I want to thank everybody that came
out in Colorado uh
I just went into that Advertiser voice
like whenever some of the ads are like
if you're doing the um
date the tour date reads that's the
voice sometimes I just noticed that
um
foreign
yeah sorry I'm amped up I feel like
there's so much to tell you guys uh
so yeah let's just start I went over to
Colorado and man it was awesome
God it was fun it was good we went to
um
we went to Pueblo
and it used to be a native town I think
in Nate you know I don't know a lot of
the history but we went there
and it's beautiful we went and saw the
mountainsides in the distance monuments
national monuments beautiful place
I mean just damn
kind of place you want to just damn push
your spouse off of you know just
beautiful Cliffs and dwellings and just
God
that's where God shows up in places like
that
that's where you get up on those
mountains and you look out and say you
can hear God saying this ain't an app
homie
Welcome to My Band with dog
look what the Lord's doing
um and that was good we've seen a lady
out there too I didn't know you know
it's a mining town
if you're not familiar with that
and uh it used to be anywhere people
mine it's just people just damn digging
in the dirt looking for something
you know and people do I mean look
people dig far
you know I grew up a lot of wishing I
grew up on the wishing well circuit and
they had a lot of people
our town was
you know semi-famous for
the number of uh wishing wells it had in
it
so you'd see people rolling through town
just down just just nickeling up the
[__] Earth baby
just [__] humming dimes into the
in the in the in the Mother Nature's
orifices you know just damn you just
if the wind blew right you could hear
damn 60 cents hitting a damn bottom of a
well somewhere
people just wishing their ass off
because we had about six whales in our
town wishing wells
and if you're not familiar with a
wishing well
a wishing well it's basically it's like
a
it's a
it's like a
place you go to wish for something that
you want and I don't know how it started
I mean I think I guess a wishing well
somebody just
somebody dropped their money into a hole
in the ground
and just wish they hadn't
I mean there's no other way for that to
have had you know
and then they probably felt so ashamed
they they just built a thing around it
and just said hey everybody come do this
[__]
but um
yeah so we went to Colorado it was man
it was just great people came out uh so
we had a couple of devout lesbians over
there at uh got in a little uh violencia
after one of the shows outside uh in
Denver that was interesting
because that's where you know
a lot of lesbians they're starting to
peek out
you know when some some lesbians they
got so much man in them that [__] will
peek out every now and then
but they were just damn trying to beat
each other and it just
you know I think and it should be if if
enough lesbian beat each other and
whoever wins gets to be a man
I mean what are we doing you know if
we're not giving goals and opportunities
if we're not you know
because if you you see two two you know
too hardcore [__] you know
wallet wanters out there
you know they out there hunting that
slick wallet homie and you see them go
at it and one of them went what did they
get
but one of them should be able to hit
that final form and unlock just basic
dude at a library yeah you don't get top
dude you got to start it you know
at you know at library dude
you got to start over there at Hogwarts
Henry babe you don't get to start just
at the top
you know you don't get to be like a uh
MacGyver or a um
who's a famous young man that's talented
Joe burrow
all right what else so anyway that was
Colorado
um and now Pueblo yeah that was a mining
town and we saw they had a woman there
we passing down the street and the
ladies over there digging in a garden
mining
we've seen a woman over there just hand
minding just looking for items and she
had damn half of a Claire's Boutique in
her hand she had probably
this [__] had a half a Zales in her
Palm
she I mean I'll you know there's
pictures right here in the YouTube if
you're watching it she had you know
it had half a Kohl's
jewelry counter right there
and it was funny because it was like who
would look she was looking in like a in
a median of a walkway where a guard
you're like who knew who would ever
look for gold there
and this lady was just hands and knees
out there
and this lady um
she she oh she cut she had a kind of a
middle aged on it she was probably
anywhere from like about 28 to maybe
[Music]
55 56.
and she looked like Greg Valentine
that's who I'm thinking of and he was a
famous wrestler and if you put them side
by side but she was out there digging in
this Garden
and he walked up and I figured maybe
she'd been on some tough times so we're
gonna you know drop her a little bit of
cash and just say hello and check in on
her and
um
she said I'm looking here I'm looking
for Treasures
and uh and then you know I asked her why
are you looking here she goes because
nobody looks here
and I looked at the space and it was
just a guard it was like a place you
wouldn't nobody even walks through it
you have to like it was up in the air
and then a garden it was like like a
kind of somebody you'd see like a they'd
put a garden in like the middle of a
walking area in a nice part of town you
know
and then she showed me in her hand and
she had damn some gold bullion in there
she had a couple
um
necklace pieces and different gold she
had real gold she'd found
and I was like damn
you know just I don't know just
interesting this lady's looking where
nobody looks
and if you just said in the beginning
hey look there
everybody said no that's crazy nobody
even walks up here you can't there's not
even a lot there's no way to get who
would walk up there
and here she was half a handful of gold
but yeah she reminded me of Greg
Valentine who I used to love and adore
and he's probably dead
all right anyway but yeah I want to tell
you then we went skiing and um
what else I got a letter from Kai The
Hitchhiker
which is
blew my mind
um went to Paris France all those things
occurred
uh
uh but yeah we went skiing and
it was magical man we went over to
Beavers Creek
and if you haven't been to Beavers Creek
it sounds like a um
it sounds like a bladder infection
really
you know it sounds like if somebody sits
down like a woman that sits down and she
can't stop her vagina maybe from making
a a sound or you know like
hey girl you know
um
wouldn't that be crazy if someone women
if they sat down in their vagina made
like a uh
like you like you guessed the wrong
answer on a game show like
um
[Music]
that would be like oh dang
that woman's got a gay dude stuck in her
vagina bro
but uh yeah we went to Beavers Creek bro
and then uh
and it was magical man it we just went
out and there was nobody out there it
was the day after Martin Luther King Jr
uh day
and uh and it was just I mean there's
nobody out there and it was oh man it
was so amazing
um
we went out there and uh oh we met this
one dude actually this was like every
dude but there was this one dude
he like worked on the slopes you know he
was like bro we caught Devil's femur bro
yeah right I mean it was fresh out of
the gate man
we got out there it was just you
couldn't hear it you could hear your
[__] dick whisper homie
we were out there man it was like I
think it was top of the morning I don't
know I've been on Molly and computer
duster for like
a while you know the doctor says I'm
going to be fine but that the residual
effects of the computer duster could
last for up to half a decade
so
but we were out there man
God it was sick Bro
Yeah I broke both of my clavicles ah
yeah I can't even hug my stepmom anymore
but it's fine she smashed like three of
my friends anyway
so whatever
my dad's rich
dude my buddy Vixen was out there with
us and we haven't seen him yeah pretty
sad he just coasted off into the Pines
up there at crippled Memphis
I don't know what I mean we're probably
gonna hold a vigil for him later if you
want to pull up yeah it's all you can
drink he'd want it that way but we're
gonna auction off his van I mean it's
not his van but his dad hated him
you're like what the [__] are we to what
what are we talking about here
some of the people that worked up there
it was another level but the place was
beautiful and a lot of great folks and
um got to go with my tour manager Tim ah
and uh and a lot of his boys from
Montana these you know a group of white
men
and it got uh everybody was chill man
everybody was chill but it was beautiful
so today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
we are grateful they are a sponsor
because when you're at your best you can
do great things that's true
you're open to possibility you're open
to things
but sometimes life gets you bogged down
and you may feel overwhelmed or like
you're not showing up in the way that
you want to
well working with a therapist really can
help
it really can
having some place to go and someone to
reflect with
someone to kind of
uh groom the trail that you're gonna
walk along someone who must help you
machete some of the
the growth
because when you're feeling empowered
you're more prepared to take on
everything that life throws at you
better help is there if you need a
therapist if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try
better help it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist at any time
I needed better help I tried it and it
worked
I had to pull over on a roadside one day
and get some dang better help and right
there bam
therapies you can text with therapist
you can FaceTime with hell I FaceTime
with one woman so I want my damn phone
overheated shut down heat warning that's
how much help I needed
if you want to live a more empowered
life
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
h-e-l-p.com slash t-h-e-o
all right we we have great calls from
you guys I want to let you know about
this this is wild so a while back uh
somebody made a face fake
of me and put it on to the
uh internet and social media
and so I am in it you know it's well
it's my face put over uh Kai The
Hitchhiker
smash smash
he's the famous smash mask Master you
know he's that handyman that [__]
couldn't find a nail cause you know who
that is
that's him baby
he's that hitchhiking nail Hunter boy
you know he's that DeWalt anyway there's
a documentary about him he's the famous
hitchhiker that hit a guy with a uh
Hatchet and hatcheted a guy out
to save a um
this kind of thicker Little Biscuit lady
who was getting her you know getting
attacked or hugged out it's the whole
story is insane
but anyway what happened was so somebody
put my face onto a Kai The Hitchhiker on
his story right it went around on social
medias we put it up on social media
um so
he filed a lawsuit he says or this
document says uh Kayla Bell mcgilvery a
jailhouse lawyer he's a apparently
according to this he's a lawyer now
um
says I've just filed a lawsuit
uh
uh because of your the video you made
um
if you want to settle outside of Court
the U.S Marshals will be coming to your
door
to hand you a summons
you'll never
um if you want to settle outside of
Court now's your chance
I'll settle for what my costs are which
is approximately
so and so amount
um
and then he wants the videos down uh
so
and he will withdraw the lawsuit
and we can go our separate ways
um I don't know
uh
I'm a jailhouse lawyer and he has nine
years of litigation experience and he
may look this is
I don't know how to handle this uh but
that's why I mean I literally
was just seeing the documentary about
him
and here is this and it's funny because
during the documentary I
I think you can relate some with this
fearile child this young man who
something was uncomfortable or wrong in
his upbringing
you know something was off
um and he appears very like kind of
manic a lot and you know also there's a
lot of transient people that's some of
the energy that's out there uh
but a good-hearted dude you know
kind of dude that would just you know
give you the skirt off his back you know
or whatever
and
that's good and I you know you kind of
love the guy
you know uh but just an amazing
interesting story and then got this this
court summons and this all appears very
real so I'm gonna have to talk with a
talk with an attorney I got a buddy over
there at Morgan and Morgan
I'll hit him up and see him maybe on the
next solo episode we can actually
address that and I can get some more
information so what else
I've been talking to a gal
and that was uh good it was cool
and then
she didn't really want to I think she
I was in her thing kinda
so that was you know that's been
interesting uh I don't know if it's been
interesting if that's the word if you
know
it was like
I don't know it's interesting when
you're trying to date or whatever and
then you kind of put yourself out there
you'd say to someone hey I'm
it's like the Hokey Pokey you put your
right foot in you know
and they then they and they put their
right foot in
so now y'all are a couple of right foot
y'all are a couple of just right foot
you know you guys are right right there
and then you're like
that left foot it wants to go in
you're like let's go let's get in let's
do it
and then you and somebody's got to put
that left foot in first usually
and I put that [__] in dog
and then it was just both of my feet and
just one of her feet was in there
and I'm like
[Music]
and
she didn't want that she don't want that
two-footed bad boy
she don't want that doses up potos
animal you know what I'm saying
and um
and she took her foot out
and then you're just standing there by
yourself
you know you're on your own two feet so
that's good but and you're in a new
place you're in like a little bit of a
braver place because you went there a
little
um
but yeah I think that [__] you know I
think it's always been tough for me to
tell somebody if I tell somebody I like
them that's always been tough for me
you know I don't want to tell you that I
don't want to it just man there's a part
inside of me it's not even me it's
something deep inside of me and it feels
very scared to say uh
very scared to say I like you
I think it's but to a woman
you know very scared to say okay I'm
I'm gonna do this uh
so I don't have a lot of self-pity but
I'm not trying to whine about it I'm
just trying to share uh what's going on
in my life and things that are
um
just
things that are just normal
you know but yeah there's something I I
talked about it a little bit on the
Louie episode and um
if you didn't get to listen to that
um it was awesome man
it was really awesome and I talked a
little bit about it on there they got a
voicemail comment about it let me see if
I can find this voicemail
Theo man it's cam down here in North
Carolina what's up cam uh thank you for
calling brother I appreciate you calling
um
cam that's a good name baby cam
could be short for uh camera
um
uh chamomile
you know this is our son chamomile yeah
soak him in hot water oh
see what happens
um
or Cam the past tense of came I guess
you know somebody
oh damn somebody ran up and just cammed
on him
you know and took off
you know or last week he got he he came
he
somebody camed on him at the house and
just
just ruined supper you know anyway
onward I just got done listening to you
and Louis C.K and I just want to
congratulate you man for the compliment
he gave you on your comedy uh
I can just imagine how good that felt
from your point of view and I was so
happy for you hearing him
speak the truth on your talent but also
I know I know he's got to be a hero for
you and that must have been a magical
moment for you I was so happy it kind of
brought a tear to my eye
well thank you man I appreciate you all
uh yeah thank you for the consideration
and for calling about that
um
you know it's interesting I texted him a
few days after
oh
because there was one thing he said in a
video there was a lot of stuff he said
in in a weird way
um
I wish I'd tried to
you know he said some things like he
said one thing
he said you can't be a pedophile if
you're a child
um
which was interesting like and I'd never
realized that I in my life I needed to I
uh when I was young there's funny you
know I don't want to say funny but
there's things that happen with kids
where you
you know people see each other's wieners
or booties or whatever you're you know
you uh people you know you're humping
your pillows and
you know like Louie was talking about
telling juicers to him and his buddy at
like summer camp and there's things that
happen you know where oh
you know I had some moments when I was a
kid when I would just hug my sister so
hard like she was a doll
and I I think I felt a lot of Shame
about that
um
and I'd never had a man
I'd never had a man say hey you're not
this is not none of this makes you a bad
person or I'd never had any that that
ever happened in my life so it was
interesting that even just sitting there
talking with him when he said that
it kind of it's
I needed that
I needed in my life to hear
a man who you know who's older than me I
don't know how old Louis is but I think
he's he could be my dad if he were had
had me at a young age
and uh
and I needed or I just needed to hear
and someone I had looked up to
in certain aspects you know I don't know
all the aspects of his life but if
someone that I had some admiration for I
needed to hear them say something like
that
and I just didn't realize it and
sometimes you don't know where those
pieces of Life hit you at you don't know
who has anybody could be could say
something that
you needed your father to say or you
needed your mother to say
um
so that was interesting and and I texted
him and I said hey you know I just
wanted to say thanks there was this
thing you said that I had needed to hear
in most of my life and I had never heard
it because I'd had a lot of Shame about
things even just about you know I think
is you have Shame about masturbating and
you know spraying out and everything and
you know
no and my dad had just had we you know
he
he didn't engage with me about any of
that or talk about it you know
he had me bury damn half of a Smurfs bed
sheet in the yard and
um
and it was just always very
uncomfortable so to even have little
moments like that uh
but I think I just found some Connection
in that call with him
um
just hearing a a voice that's
knowledgeable but not he wasn't
judgmental
um obviously he's been through all the
nooks and crannies of of you know uh
sexual discussion and thought probably
in his own head and so yeah just to have
like an adult say that
don't you know that you can't be
you're not bad for it was I don't know
it was kind of blanket but it just hit
me and I needed to hear that and I never
knew I did
um
so anyway there were moments like that
anyway sorry to interrupt your call so
much let's go onward and uh the reason
for that is just because you put
yourself out here and you make yourself
vulnerable and there's a lot of us out
here that really benefit from me and uh
I know when I'm going through some [__]
I can tune in to listen to you and yeah
you know I feel better
I appreciate you
and uh just keep doing this thing here
gang baby thanks cam I appreciate that
call man
um
yeah there was some moments with Louis
where I just felt yeah uh
yeah you know I don't know what else to
do except
be myself sometimes
I know it might sound crazy but I don't
know there's so much inside of myself
that wants to get out of me
[Music]
um
and there's things I want to say that I
don't I don't know what they are
there's things out that are inside of my
name I think there's conversations I
never got to [__] have as a kid I
think there's a lot of [__] just inside
of me
that it's like
you know and I noticed people say hey
don't you know don't think about the
past and I'm not thinking about it
but if that [__] lives in me dog
you know and I think there's a lot of
like I don't know
you know I'm a late bloomer man I know I
am and that's okay
you know
if you go through a total childhood of
not getting to have interaction or to
talk or have any idea what your feelings
are or help somebody mold what feeling
even is
and you're just surviving in the [__]
world
and then at some point you start to quit
trying to survive
then you uh you still have a whole I
still have a whole
I still have a whole Rolodex of [__]
that I didn't get to get right or I
never got to even get wrong
um
yeah I don't know man some of that [__]
makes me [__] you know and some of it
still makes me angry sometimes there's a
lot of I mean I got so much I got a lot
of anger in me sometimes
and people say forgive and forget I I
get that
I'm in a program doing all that [__]
but that you just because you say you
forgive doesn't mean that something just
disappears
you know
um
because some of this [__] man it [__]
lives in me
you know
sometimes there's still a kid inside of
me that's so [__] angry bro
you know and it's my job as an adult
just to not not to let him drive the
boat you know
um anyway I'm not trying to get into
self-pity but there was just a lot
during that that conversation you know
it's like
I'm still collecting
conversations that should have happened
when I was a kid
and I'm out here you know
trying to collect them as an adult
um
and not even collect them I'm trying to
I just don't know where they're gonna
happen
and sometimes I don't know that they are
going to happen it just one thing you
know you could do you know so I'm just
grateful that God lets me be alive and
that gives me an opportunity to have
some experiences but thank you for the
call dude I was excited
um I felt like we had a good connection
I didn't know I was scared
I'd seen Louis one time in the hall at
The Comedy Store when he was very uh
famous in mainstream media and
um
you know I I he seemed very standoff as
she seemed like a fancy guy
and uh but I also didn't know him but um
he didn't seem like approachable or
anything
but uh
but I I I was I felt I felt excited to
get invited to his show I hadn't gone to
a comedy show and
uh uh I'd been like the first comedy
show I'd ever been to
and then
I'd been to I went to see Bob Newhart
one time in Chicago and then I saw Louie
of actual show where I went and went and
just sat in the audience and watched
I've seen a ton of sets at The Comedy
Store in that but anyway this is getting
a little bit long here so
all right let's get into a little bit of
news here and then we'll go on to the uh
I'll tell you about the fashion show
what happened here uh in the news
we got
um Alabama woman who joined Isis once
back in the U.S
nope
bye [__] that's what I'm saying
a woman who left Alabama joined the
Islamic State in 2014 now says she
regrets her actions and is hoping to
return to the United States
if I need to sit in prison and do my
time I will do it I won't fight against
it oh now that's interesting
that could be fair
but I don't know you know I I get to it
gets to a point where as a country you
make so many
bins of whatever your original rules are
that you're not a country anymore
you know if you have like at the pool
rules say you have the pool rules and
these are the rules you can't swim
during this hours
you can't uh
no swimming 30 minutes after
sandwiches or dining
no diarrheas
no uh
pissing in the pool or whatever duking
so you have those rules but then you
start Breaking All the Rules I'll change
this for we'll change this rule change
this Rule and then you have somebody
that comes up
and this lady whatever just sprayed tit
milk on the rules
and went off to another country to join
a group that was against your original
country
I say bye
I say bombing because you changed it
then there's no more rules then this
pool doesn't exist
now you got people eating out of the
pool making soup you got one dude
diarrhea and down here by the ladder the
ducks have fecal Alcohol Syndrome from
The
uh duties at the other end and then
somebody's selling duck you got a
Chinese dude selling duck meat on the
side of the pool
you know you got some fella over there
just huffing down duck empanadas and he
gets infected because of the god about a
ladder just the whole thing but it's all
because the rules keep getting adjusted
so I say
no
you left you said [__] this place
then that you made your go pick another
place then
if Isis didn't work out you didn't cut
it in Isis
all right go play back play Hoops in
Russia boo
and some of my reasoning behind with the
rules is because at a certain point that
people that care about that like going
to the pool in the beginning they're not
going to want to be at the pool anymore
they're gonna they're not Nobody's Gonna
Wanna be at the pool
so now you've made all these adjustments
about the pool
and you don't have a pool anymore
now you got a Duck Soup diarrhea Farm
that's what you got
and the people that originally cared
about the pool that made it the pool
they're not going to care anymore
they're gonna find some other place
they're gonna get into private areas and
have their own pool they're going to
figure it out
so I don't know
I just liked it better when and maybe
it's just me and this is just my
perspective
but when it felt like we all
we all had the same pool in mind
um what else parents in shock as
gorillas mate in front of kids at Zoo
a pair of gorillas at a zoo
left parents shocked as they decided to
start doing it like they do on the
Discovery Channel right in front of the
kids
when you take the kids to the zoo to see
all the wonders of the animal kingdom
you've always got to understand there's
a risk that all creatures great and
small will be up to some naughty antics
I love this
hell I think the zoo could charge more
for animal sex hours honestly
if you come at 2 pm that's when
everybody's [__] you know what I'm
saying bruh
because you go to some of these cages
now you go to the lion cage he's in
there he's always sleeping or he's laid
out or he's on looks like he's on a
couple zannies you know
they always got a kick ball next to him
you who's ever seen a lion play kickball
what [__] lion gets up and he's like
then you see another lion run up and
just
and the other lions are like Roar kick
it kick it it's there's no [__] that's
what do they do they're not doing
anything
and then and there's always like a tight
rope in the cage going from like one
tree to another
like the line like the Lion's just gonna
like oh just like walk on the road like
Oh I'm a rope lion I'm a tightrope lion
[__] what the [__]
they don't do [__] man
I'm sick of paying entry fees to see
animals not do [__] they don't do [__]
these animals don't do [__] they just
lay there like Rich animals that's all
they are
because we took him out of the Wild
the wild is where God is out there
setting it off
and Mother Nature's out there [__]
twerking
and people are eating BBQ and getting
gunned down
but we take them out of the natural
environment we put them in this Rich ass
[__] Maxim or minimum security prison
and they're living large they're
kickballing they're eating lamb
they're I saw one video they're feeding
lamb to Lambs
I'm sick of these rich ass animals
that's all this is man have you ever
lived in a shitty neighborhood and then
moved to a better neighborhood
have you ever moved from Memphis to
Nashville
okay that's what's happening with these
animals
and people are like we got to set the
animals free
no we what
if we set the animals free every penguin
will be at in at Albertsons in the
frozen food section
you'll have every penguin in there
[__] just just beating open a thing
of fish sticks
every leopard will kill every missing
pet in your area
there will be zero missing animals
you can't free you can't free these
animals man
because they'll be right back in nature
they'll be right back in the wild
and the wild the wildest gangster
that's the UFC for Animals man
these animals they have a good in the
zoo they got it really really good
so why say we either put them to work or
tell them to take a four-legged hike
I want to go to the zoo and they got I
want to go during they should have
animal sex hours in the afternoon two to
three p.m everybody [__]
all right forty dollars to get in
you that Zoo would be packed
that Zoo would be even the French would
be there like
but we got to get these animals to work
these Zoo they're not making any money
nobody's going to see you could watch a
nationally fight immediately
The Dana White should do the nature
Channel
these [__] fight immediately on the
nature Channel
so these animals I think they either
need to step it up or get the hey
that's what I'm saying I want to go to
the zoo I want to see you know I want to
see uh I want to see the end I want to
see these Apes fists fighting I want to
see the rats making soup like they do in
the movie I want to see
um Penguins miming why aren't Penguins
miming
you got the colors do the [__] work
boys
but zoos could easily Step It Up 2 p.m
all the animals [__]
that's easy
2 p.m all the animals [__] 40 dollars to
get in bring a rain Slicker boom
now we're talking business baby
but I think if you go to the zoo and see
some animals [__] lucky you all right
just make sure that you have a
conversation with your son or daughter
afterwards to explain what happened and
that they shouldn't feel ashamed for
watching it
thank you
four NFL teams two Conference
Championship games and only a few more
shots to win big on the NFL playoffs
with DraftKings sports book an official
sports betting partner of the NFL
counting down to Super Bowl 57 new
customers can bet just five dollars and
get 200 in free bets instantly
if you're not a new customer you can
feel the conference Championship thrills
with stepped up same game parlays take
your shot at an even bigger NFL payout
and boost your winnings with each leg
you add up to 100 percent that's right
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code Theo new customers can put
five dollars on the conference
championships and get 200 and free bets
instantly only at draftking Sportsbook
with code Theo minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details and make sure that you
are okay to gamble if you have a
gambling problem this might not be for
you
let's move on what else do we have a
couple calls that came in this episode's
getting long that's okay went to France
let me have a sip of my Celsius man
I went to France
so this thing came out of nowhere right
get invited to go to France
um and you know I don't like the French
you know it
if you had to pick six things I don't
like the French would be four of them
and uh so I got invited they were doing
a comedy fashion show this fellow kids
super
and at first they said kid super I
thought it was one of you know like a
Make-a-Wish fellas you know you simply
get those
you know they got that 40 year old in a
cape or something and he's
you know he wants to jump out of a wind
or whatever and they won't let him
because he's
you know does he never
you know he's mentally he's really you
know because the devil tickled him
whenever he was being made or whatever
and he's not well
um but it wasn't it was a uh it was a
fashion
show
put on by this um fella comb Delane make
sure I get his name correctly comb
Delane yes any real beautiful fella
Manor really kind smart neat guy
um and I'd had a friend Aaron Levy that
was uh part of the John Elliott clothing
brand so I'd been around some clothing
fashion High fashion
and I don't know much about fashion you
know that I mean look at me
there you go and you know I don't and uh
you know I got three pairs of pants I
wear one of them all the time this is it
these little camo deals it's paper thin
but they're nice from North Face and I
like them
um
but anyway we get invited to this thing
and it they said it's gonna be I mean
you're wearing I mean some of the linen
it's just damn fresh silk I mean this
you could smell a spider's [__] on it
you know this [__] is hot
hot off the eight arms baby you know
what I'm saying this [__] is fresh and
um
and so yeah we we we go we first of all
we get to the airport and they're taking
us on a jet I mean this thing Puma put
us on a jet
and it's uh I mean this thing was long
this thing had two bathrooms in it
and I pissed in both of them cuz you
know that boy
if there's I'm piss in it you know what
I'm saying I'm pissing at each end of
the yard baby
and I'll let the devil do the laundry
baby you know what I'm saying I'm
pissing when I get in something
that's always who I've been
you know as a child at night before I go
to bed I'd piss off each side of my bed
and I'd piss around it fraud stand on my
bed and urinate around it
just uh to keep
you know whatever bad stuff could come
get me to keep it away
um
but anyway uh so we went there uh who
was there Andrew Santino
um
uh Mateo Lane other comedians uh Stavros
halkias
um fari
and he's a French comedian
um
who else Jeff Ross couple of the
comedians
um yeah anyway so we went out on the
stage and we had to walk in a fashion
and we had to uh do the you know and do
some material on stage so that was part
of it
and it was just while you know like
there I mean if you know I I
this was the most nervous that I'd been
to do comedy in a long time because for
one
people are coming to ju they judge
clothing I mean this is like fancy
people this is like the fanciest people
everybody has a Blog everybody has a web
page everybody has a lawyer it's people
like that
you know uh
and so you get it's like I knew these
people were going to be are judgmental
about clothes anyway they're gonna
they're they're here to judge clothing
all week
so if you throw in an outlier like a
comedian
who's coming in who's not even part of
their world
we're the easiest thing for them to hate
on oh I can hate on this guy oh easy
done comedian done
so I feel I was like oh these are my
first man and it was rich people bro
and I don't like the rich man
I've said it and you know it
and people say well man you make money
and I yeah I do
but I'll never be rich
I'll never be [__] infected with that
[__]
that [__] starts in your heart son
so I'll never I won't be like that
and I know because when I get around
rich people I don't like them
and I just felt that in there it's that
age-old energy man
you know because they had a rich doctor
when I was young they had a rich
veterinarian right
and he would uh he would drive through
our neighborhood sometimes people would
cut through
from the highway there and then they had
another Highway and in between the two
highways was our neighborhood and
off of that people would cut through our
neighborhood and drive off to one of the
down one of the highways and be nice
neighborhoods and they had this uh
veterinarian and he would throw
animals dead animals out in our ditch
and [__] when they drove by
you know
and so that [__] always stuck with me
man
you know like oh this is just the place
where they
that's what they think of of this that's
what they think of us
this is just a place where we put dead
animals
um
and you could damn use Clorox you would
never get that [__] out of my system
but anyway and I know this is a
judgmental play people are judging
fashion people are here to be judged
so I know the easiest thing for some
blogger
which is basically just a job where you
are afraid to [__] fight
uh the easiest job for a blogger is to
say to point fingers at the outlier that
comes in to say this is bad
right
um
instead of you know saying this is good
from all the you know
bribes or whatever they get I don't know
or whatever their end goal is
but anyways say this bad so I just knew
going up against it was going to be
tough and it turned out uh it was okay
and we did well and and um
yeah the kids super clothing you know
it's nice neat stuff and calm the guy
who runs it was very neat Andrew Schultz
was there that was fun to get to spend
time with him
um it was great man that was exciting
um I went for a walk
oh
I didn't try to do too much in France
because I wasn't there long
and you get out in the streets and this
you know it's French
people are French and you know just
[__] Frenching around dog
but we got to go out at night we went
and they had nice music at night and
just the whole experience was fancy and
it actually ended up being a good
experience
um sometimes I carry old ideas into
things uh
and so I gotta kind of monitor that
um
but my nerves are warnings for me and
they say hey this is what's up
beware of this
and uh and I'm glad that they're there
those are instincts too sometimes it's
not nerves it's instincts
and you got to really ask them are you a
nerve are you an instinct tell me
you got to figure it out okay let's get
into a caller too
um
here we go something that came from you
guys here we go
hi Theo uh this is Faye from Salt Lake
City
hello Faye from Salt Lake baby
and I like salt
onward
um I just wanted to say that I love this
show
um and it's had more of an impact than
you would probably think
um because if it is oddly enough the
only thing that calms down my 78 year
old grandma with dementia
um if you don't know dementia is when
the Lord starts deleting all the files
in your brain yeah I'm like her main
caregiver oh yeah
that's a spyware baby the devil's
spyware baby onward yeah I'm like her
main caregiver uh
outside of my grandpa so three days a
week she's over here and she gets real
Restless without him
uh one day my fiance had the idea to
just throw on this past weekend put it
on the TV cast it from YouTube to the TV
and it was like magic and now like the
whole family knows to do it when she's
getting nervous
oh
well that's sweet
that's really sweet I think it's sweet
that you spend time with your
grandmother I'm sorry that
that
that parts of her just kind of eroding
back into the universe you know
that's a lot
you know I'm amazed how much care you
have in you that's pretty fascinating
um
and I'm grateful that
somehow maybe I'm able to be a part of
uh
of spending time with her
you know my dad was 76 when he passed
and it's nice now I get to spend time
with a 78 year old
that's nice
you know that's nice it's uh
there's all these little ways that we
get
our Loose Ends kind of tied you know
so many unexpected ways let me hear more
just that first order of business is
throwing Theo give her some ice cream
and throw on Theo now I see what now I
think she might have y'all I think a lot
of this is about the ice cream and
that's how I look so a lot of people
will fake dementia to get ice cream
and who can blame him homie
to be honest I go live in a senior
center right now
I think of the age you got to be is 55
or 59 write a lot of them in Arkansas
they I I think it's I want to say 54.
but I in a heartbeat I would go live in
you get games every day with other
people right you can play board games at
four 4 45 bro y'all [__] eating [__]
I go live in a senior center right now
you know how much work and enjoyable
things you would get done play the piano
talk to somebody about a war
I mean God you know
put up a wanted poster of Bobby Lee
outside of your door
VFW meeting tonight
in the game room you know what I'm
talking about
and it's crazy she thinks that you're
here in the living room with her talking
to her and she just she thinks she's
talking to you basically she thinks
she's a guest
um but yeah I'm I'm a fan Grandma's a
fan whole family really
well man I'm honored to have her on
every single week
maybe it'd be interesting to have her on
I don't know I'm having my producer
reach out this is I mean I you know it
may be a lot to put somebody with that
on but there could be some Fascination
to it uh but I'm happy to have her I'm
happy that she is a guest every week and
uh I'm happy to be a little part of
y'all's lives and for sharing that she's
a part of mine that's awesome dude
that's so cool
thank you and give her a hug for me if
you're allowed to touch her I don't know
if people like being touched or not if
they are
demented or whatever
all right let's get one more call here
that came in
uh let's go
hey Theo this is John from Minneapolis
Minnesota what's up John from
Minneapolis and sorry about what
happened to your Vikings but
y'all beat the Saints a while back on
that Minnesota Miracle so that's life
bruh
I've been listening to your podcast now
for about a year and over the course of
this year I've just been uplifted by its
so much
I worked for my dad and I I
listen to your podcast almost every
single day uh he owns a window cleaning
business and was recently diagnosed with
stage four brain cancer so me and my
brother have been having to kind of take
over for him
and it's just been a really tough time
for my family through this uh
anyways I know you lost your father
Tandy young and young myself not as
young as you were but I'm only 21.
and I'm just hoping you might have some
advice for me on how to move forward
through this time of life
uh just finding it real hard
you know I uh I talked about this a
little bit on the Louis episode where
you know uh my dad had a girlfriend in
his later years and
we went over to her I was over at her
house one night and
she had a nice house man and this the
it looked like a
it was like a big apart like a condo and
I'd never been in a condo before and it
had like big windows and
she made these roast beef sandwiches and
the roast beef was like in a pot and it
had like sauce with it and
I'd never seen anything like it
you know I just felt like uh
I just felt like the meat itself had
and just drowned itself and
done it on purpose for me it just it was
that good you know
and uh
and
I remember being over there one night
my dad had gotten uh I didn't know that
my dad was sick right and
and in the middle of the night we would
sleep out on the couch at her place
because they didn't have
um
because my dad was sleeping in the extra
she had an extra room my dad would sleep
in there and then we slept on the couch
but the couch was a nice boy and
[Music]
um
and and my daddy got up in the middle of
the night he was going down the hall
towards her room and
um
and I was I was awake and I was like
what is he doing is he
you know was my dad sexually active I
didn't know you know I didn't know what
they were doing you know I knew it could
have I just didn't know
and so I kind of went over there you
know because I'm uh
pervert
and I went and I saw that my dad had
like uh
he had like diarrhea himself
and
um
and he was going to ask her he was
asking her for help you know and uh
uh and yeah it just
[Music]
um
and like six weeks after that he he
passed away I mean that was when I first
found out that he was sick
um
and
yeah I think it was just such a moment
of like okay here's is this guy's
what is is there sex going here or what
and then it is scary it was just a lot
of stuff
you know uh
so yeah I can't you know I don't know
what's going on in your world and so I
didn't mean to make that about me it
just that made me think about that and I
just talked about it on that Louis
episode a little bit
um
but just that it was this scary
you know and I remember being scared
um and you know it I it's so neat that
your dad has a business that you and
your brother are working in that's so
cool that's a piece of him
you know
that's a PCM that's things that we miss
in the world is when our dads would do
something and then the sons would carry
it on and it wasn't like
you know before everything got all
globalized and
we sold out a lot of our values for
uh
per
the benefit of few you know and
um
sorry that was a little political there
but uh it was when they you know
more mom and pop operations because with
Mom and Pop come children and then the
children become the mom and pop and then
there's something you created that
carries on through you you know uh
but um
but it's beautiful you guys have that
you know and sometimes if I want to
think about my dad or feel what he feels
like you know I uh
I'll
I'll put my hand like on my heart
um
because my heartbeat came from my dad
you know and my mom and so I'm a remix
of my parents
um
and when I miss my dad uh
you know this is the sound that he made
it's a sound that he made
that was in him part of the sound that's
inside of me the beat that comes in me
that stays alive was in my father
and the only place it is now is in me
you know it's in my siblings too but
part of it is in me
and that's his sound that is his sound
um
and that gives me some Solace sometimes
it gives me uh
some Solace sometimes
um
but I'm sorry you guys are doing that
I'm blessed it's it's a blessing you
have a brother there to go through it
with you
um
and you're able you're you have a
relationship with your father it sounds
like you're going to be able to deal
with some of this and process it and
and I would get some recordings with
your dad if he if he is still alive I
couldn't tell from the call and spend
some time with him as much as you can
and get some of that video and audio
recorded too always have that
um you know I don't I have a few
pictures from my dad uh
and
you know they're his other family took
everything else and uh yes I'm kind of
resentful about that [__]
um
but anyway I'm sorry you're going
through that man thanks for sharing
um and keep sharing it with people
because other people are gonna have
little things that will help you
and
um
that's what I got man
what else
yeah I didn't mean to finish up on a
downer there I love watching Brianna
Brandon Moreno fight uh I'm so happy for
him baby that was amazing
um I can't believe I got to go to France
what the heck man uh
I'm excited this week we'll be in
Louisville and Indianapolis
um some new shows are on sale and
um
yeah just thank you guys for being a
part of my life
uh
and
you know just try and be good to
yourselves you know that's the same
thing I'm gonna do I haven't had
anything to eat today except for this
caffeine and some antidepressants so
I'm gonna go meet my friend Tim and eat
and
um
yeah
you know you we just don't know where
the possibility is going to come from
you know and if I shut myself all the
way off then I might not I might miss it
and there's still a part of me that
wants to shut myself all the way off
isn't that crazy I want to I want to
just close it down I'm not talking about
take my life or anything I'm just saying
you know I want to make myself
unavailable
but
but uh but then we might miss out
you know
and so you step back in you put the
right foot in
you put the left foot in
and some somebody great something
whatever
something's going to come and meet you
there
you know
and actually you know what I'm going to
change it up we're going to go out
like we sometimes do man I love you guys
thank you for being a part of my life
this week uh if you're struggling with
something
um you just gotta make it through today
you don't have to make it through a
million years you don't have to make it
through 40 years you don't have to make
it through 10 years you have to make it
through today
you know and uh
you got this [__] baby gang baby
we got this [__] baby gang
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
porch wondering how could I be so far
from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
find it I'll patch up where it's been
Brown
now I'm just